It says, "Can you speak about ALS, Lou
Gehrig's disease, amyotrophic lateral
sclerosis?"
I talk about ALS, I also will be talking
about MS, multiple sclerosis, and also
Huntington's disease, and also
Parkinson's. All four are approached the
same way with nutrition.
Parkinson's, Huntington's disease, MS,
and ALS, Lou Gehrig's disease, all four.
So, nobody will need to ask about these
cuz it'll be the same approach
nutritionally.
I'm going to talk about 100 lb. This
The dose goes by poundage. So, we'll
talk about a dosage for 100 lb.
It'll be one healthy brain and heart
pack.
One healthy brain and heart pack per 100
lb of body weight.
Remember, that's for those four
diseases.
And
I get an extra bottle of the secret
sauce we call selenium. And so, they can
take six a day, three at breakfast,
three at dinner, or two at breakfast,
lunch, and dinner.
And then, I also take
a um a program we call Synaptiv.
If you know about brain function,
synapse where the one nerve fiber speaks
to another, synapse,
uh s y n a p t i v.
Okay?
Synaptiv,
Synaptiv, okay? And um want you to take
three of those twice a day per 100 lb of
body weight, it'll be two bottles a
month.
Synaptiv.
And then,
um you need to eat eight eggs a day per
100 lb of body weight. They cannot be
fried, they cannot be cooked in oil or
margarine, they have to be either
poached with a soft yolk, or a soft
boiled with a soft yolk, or soft, soft,
soft, soft scrambled in butter.
And that's to give you the
the um
cholesterol necessary to rebuild the
brain, the part of the brain that's
damaged.
They're all really the same disease,
it's just a matter of where in the brain
the more severe damage occurs, you get a
different symptom based on the different
parts of the brain.
They give it a different name. You can
have all You could have all four. You
could have MS, ALS,
uh Parkinson's and Huntington's at the
same time.
But doctors will pick the name of the
one that's most obvious and give it that
name.
Okay, so there you go.
ALS, MS, Huntington's disease and
Parkinson's disease. Okay, gentlemen,
yes, sir.
Dr. Wallach,
I I thank you
Okay, this microphone isn't working very
well.
I I
I need to turn it on or
or get closer or
I thank you.
Thank you. Okay. I thank you for being
here.
Thank you. Uh
you just talking about the brain.
I've been hit in the head a couple of
times.
Pretty good.
Now, is this Is this with a baseball?
Falling off the roof or
a brick.
A brick
steel coming down about 35 ft. Okay.
Knocked me on my knees.
I have problems with my knees and my
hip. Okay.
Uh
Okay.
Maybe you could prescribe something for
me.
Sure, very very easy. The brain wants to
recover. The brain can heal itself,
contrary to what doctors say. Your brain
can heal itself very nicely.
Um and your nerves in your neck and your
vertebrae and your hips and knees.
And so, um what I would do is take two
of the healthy brain and heart packs for
a month.
Two This is for head trauma. Two healthy
brain and heart packs a month, a full
dose of everything
um at breakfast and full dose of
everything at dinner time cuz you weigh
somewhere around 200 lb, give or take a
few pounds.
And I would also take the Synaptiv
again, take three of those twice a day.
I'd also take the
um
eight to 10 eggs a day.
I'd also throw in the Gluco Gel. The
Gluco Gel is the secret sauce to support
and promote maintenance and repair of
cartilage, ligaments, tendons,
connective tissue, disc between the
vertebrae, back, hips, knees. I'd have
you take 15 of those a day, five at
breakfast, five at lunch, five at
dinner. And this goes for anybody that
has
osteoporosis,
osteopenia,
arthritis, bone marrow arthritis,
rheumatoid arthritis,
uh bone spurs, calcium deposits,
periodontal disease.
And whatever pack you take, you want to
also take those two bottles of gluco
gel. So you take 15 a day, so they'll
support and promote maintenance, repair
cartilage, ligaments, tendons,
connective tissue, disc pain, vertebrae,
okay? Thank you.
You're very welcome, sir. God bless you.
God bless. Okay, I'm going to jump over
here.
Yes?
I just want to welcome you for being
here today. Get a little closer.
There you go. Thank you, pastor. Good
afternoon. I just wanted to welcome you
for being here today. It's Thank you.
Very gracious. Thank you. Also, I wanted
to ask you about um I have a history of
pulmonary embolism.
And um it imitates the factor five.
You know, if your mother have it, you
have it, but it isn't.
So, I wanted you to give me some advice
on that.
Okay, pulmonary embolism is a blood
clot, okay, caused by deficiency of
omega-3 essential fatty acids,
whether it's a blood clot in the brain,
heart, or the lung.
Pulmonary embolism means there's one of
these blood clots in the lung caused by
a deficiency of omega-3s or a ratio
problem between omega-3s, sixes, and
nines.
And
uh
obviously, when you take in inflammatory
things like fried foods, it makes it
worse. It It makes the lining of the
arteries all inflamed, so it makes the
deficiencies worse.
And um
so what I would do is I go ahead and
take um two of the healthy brain and
heart packs a month, full dose for you
twice a day. I'd also take what we call
the ultimate daily
um
classic.
Ultimate daily classic are tablets. I'd
go ahead with one bottle
a month and that's going to allow you to
take three of those tablets twice a day.
And what it's going to do
is support healthy
dilation
of the blood vessels in your lungs. It's
also going to support healthy blood
clotting system so you're not going to
have a blood clot when you don't need
one.
And it's the ultimate daily classic.
Take three of those twice a day. It's an
addition to the health two healthy brain
and heart packs. None of the bad stuff
and no fried foods or processed meats or
also gluten. So next time I say none of
the bad stuff, everybody knows what that
is.
And um
it's not genetic. The reason why your
mom has it and you have it is because
she has a gluten intolerance and she's
passed that on to you through cord
blood. Do you have children? Yes. Do any
of them have any asthma?
Yes. Bingo!
Okay? That's because those things are
all caused by gluten intolerance.
Wow.
And so it's a trail from your mom's
mother. All her sisters and brothers
have it.
Your aunties on your mama's side have
passed it on to their children. If you
have daughters, they better be
gluten-free because if they're not
gluten-free, they will pass it on to
their children. If they're gluten-free,
they won't. Wow.
That's awesome. Uh as a matter of fact,
I never was asymptomatic of asthma until
now. Mhm. And but my kids always like
like, "Mom, you cleaning and that Clorox
and you know, the smells while
a deficiency.
Okay, so now you know what to do. God
bless you. God bless you. Thank you so
much.
Okay. Dr. Wallach, side note. Um for
people that um how do we handle So
someone's out there listening, they hear
you address someone that has what
they're struggling with. How do they
handle that in terms of going to the
table?
Well, they already know if they're
standing outside if they're here, they
go right to the table. So if they're
sitting out there and you address
something that they have
go right to the table.
tell them what they have. Just not here
If they're streaming Oh. What do we do
if they're streaming? Uh basically, what
I would do is collect some of this
information on a piece of paper like you
gave me before. Uh we're going to answer
one of those every time we do two of
these uh kind of thing, but
you're blessed in having
um Michael and Kim because they're very
knowledgeable.
And so you can email these things to
them uh later. I mean, you can do this
for the next 6 years. You email these
things to them and they will know what
to do. Okay, just not 10 minutes.
take them home with them. Okay.
The webs What's the website? Can we give
the website?
Well, they have to We'll do it before we
close.
the website from them. Okay. Because we
have thousands of website based on
individuals and so I I try not to have
any in my head. Okay, so everybody clear
if if Dr. Wallach answers a question
that you of what you're dealing with
with somebody else, that you can just
get try to remember what he said, but
more so go out to the table and tell
them I have this and they'll tell you.
Does everybody got it? Okay.
Hey, your turn. Hi Dr. Wallach.
Um what would your um
diagnosis be for? I'm a 32-year-old
woman who's had two heart attacks
already. Okay, two heart attacks. This
was a blood clot in the heart,
cardiomyopathy, bleeding heart attack,
what kind of heart attack?
Blood clot in the heart. Say again?
Blood clot. I have four four stents.
Uh but my cardio says cardiologist
doesn't talk about nutrition at all. I'm
sorry, I didn't hear that last piece.
my cardiologist doesn't recommend
anything nutritionally for me at all.
Well, it's because he knows nothing
about nutrition.
Okay, so uh you're kind of a big girl.
What do you weigh? 200. 200, okay. I
would take two Healthy Brain and Heart
Paks a month. Does that sound Does that
sound familiar? Anytime a heart's
involved, blood vessels involved, heart
attack, stroke. So, you want two Healthy
Brain and Heart Paks a month, a full
dose of everything at breakfast, full
dose of everything at dinnertime.
I would also get the ultimate um
Don't play with your paper.
Yeah, put the paper on the floor.
Thank you.
You're okay.
Yeah.
Um, you also want the um Ultimate Daily
Classic. Go ahead and take three of
those at breakfast, three at dinner
time, in the bottom of the month,
Ultimate Daily Classic.
And then I would also throw in
the what we call the um
Ultimate Cardio Sticks. The Ultimate
Cardio Sticks, so you tear the top off,
you put them in a bottle of water and
drink it. I would go ahead and take two
of those a day, it's one per 100 lb of
body weight. So, one at breakfast, one
at dinner time.
And they're going to support blood flow
through blocked arteries, they're going
to support um
uh lowering blood pressure. I don't know
if you have a blood pressure problem
associated with this sometimes.
But, uh this is all nutritional
deficiencies. This is easily dealt with.
And you do have to stay away from the
bad stuff, the fried foods, the
processed meats, the oils, the gluten,
right?
Okay?
And again, the reason why your doctors
don't talk to you about nutrition is
because they don't know much about it.
It's probably good that they don't talk
about it.
I have one more question. Um No, no, you
only get one.
Apologize, you only get one.
Okay.
Just one.
Yes.
Hi, yeah. Hello. I just wanted to
clarify um with autism, you said that it
was
is it something that's
there's anything to do now or I have a
6-year-old that has autism. Um I'm
missing that last part. I have a
6-year-old who has autism. Okay, autism.
Autism is not genetic. Autism is a
nutritional deficiency of the brain.
We're talking about autism, ADD, ADHD,
depression, manic depression, bipolar
disease. Bipolar disease when you're in
civilian clothes.
When you have PTSD,
K, post-traumatic um stuff, this is when
you're in a military uniform, it's
really just bipolar. And then there's
schizophrenia, and then there's
psychoses, anxiety attack, panic attack,
it's all caused by the same thing.
It's one or more deficiencies of the
brain. The brain requires all 90
essential nutrients. Now, kids can be
born perfectly normal,
and then if they're deficient in their
formula or the mother's deficient in the
breast milk, then the baby will
gradually over time, it could be days or
weeks, get autism. Or the baby can be
born with autism. There's nothing
mechanically or physically wrong with
the brain. So that uh something that's
fixable. Sometimes babies have autism,
but they also have the equivalent of
even if the mother didn't drink or take
drugs, they might have the equivalent of
what would be called uh fetal alcohol
syndrome, where they do have some
permanent retardation cuz there's a
little piece missing in the brain cuz
the mom was missing something.
And then you can get rid of the autism
piece, and the kid will be significantly
better, but not perfect. So I mean,
there's all these possibilities without
talking to the kid and knowing more
history, it'd be hard to tell which one.
Well, she can't talk, so she wouldn't
She She was born normal and she sort of
developed this at age four?
She developed it. She was diagnosed at
age two.
Age two. She was diagnosed
two, yeah. Well, she was okay until she
was two, then she developed it at age
two, it's reversible.
Okay? So, what I would do
with a child like that, uh what does she
weigh?
50 50 lb? Yeah. Yeah. So, what I would
do is get her one Healthy Body and Heart
Pack.
That's going to last her two months.
That's meant for 100 lb for a month. So,
she weighs 50 lb, that's a two-month
supply.
And um you mix up a full dose of
everything like it says, and then give
her a quarter of a dose at breakfast,
quarter of a dose at dinner, so that's
her half for the day, right?
And that should last her that whole
package should last her two months.
But get away from the bad stuff. Again,
last time, no fried foods, no processed
meats or oils, no gluten. In her case,
no sugar. That means no fruit juice, no
fruit. She can get everything she needs
from fruit from vegetables. Mhm.
Uh no stir-frying. And you got to keep
them away from the bad stuff, because
that's where the problem lies. Okay?
Okay.
Very good. Question?
Hi Dr. Wallach. Um thank you for coming.
My question is um what can I do or use
for a imbalance? I have uh
I my body wants to go straight,
but it leans and sometimes I have
difficulty walking. Okay, now is this
she has a balance problem. Now, is this
a um
Cere-
cerebellar something. Okay, were you
born this way? No, not to my knowledge.
it's not cerebellum. Well, that's what
they say. That's what the doctor say.
Okay, yes, not cerebellum. It's not
cerebral palsy if you're born normal. Uh
how long ago did this develop?
It's been going on for about a year and
a half.
Okay, so a year and a half. Yeah, so
it's not a genetic defect. It's not a
congenital defect.
Uh-huh. You weren't born that way.
And this can be due to osteoporosis of
the skull. Okay. Or you could have one
hip, you know, one leg shorter than the
other. I mean, there's all kinds of
possibilities here.
But if it has to do with the with the
brain, uh doctors forget that you get
osteoporosis of the skull just like you
do your legs and your pelvis and your
vertebrae.
When you have osteoporosis of your
skull,
the bones get thicker. Often times it be
called Paget's disease. When it gets
thicker, the canals that the nerves come
through, there's 12 pairs of cranial
nerves. 12 come out this side of the
brain, 12 come out from this side of the
brain.
And the one that affects your balance
and then you feel like you're maybe in
motion. Do you ever get like motion
sickness, a little nausea with it?
Yes, sometimes.
get ringing in your ears? Or no tone or
chirping or anything?
No.
Okay. But if you feel a little nauseous
sometime and you feel like, man, the
room is swimming like I'm, you know,
motion sickness,
um this could be caused by osteoporosis
of the skull. And the canal that the
eighth cranial nerve is going through is
filling up with scar tissue
because you have osteoporosis of the
skull.
And when you squeeze the uh vestibular
branch of the eighth cranial nerve, in
the old days you used to call it
Meniere's disease, and today they call
it Wallach's vertigo cuz they figured
out what causes it.
Right.
So, what you need to do, you're a tall
girl, so you you you're going to need
two healthy bone and joint packs a
month. Okay. Two full doses a day, a
full dose at breakfast and dinner. Two
healthy bone and joint packs a month.
And um you also want to In each one One
those healthy bone and joint packs is
going to be a wide mouth jar of CM
cream, which is a topical pain reliever,
anti-inflammatory. We're going to take a
quarter of a teaspoon with a Q-tip in
the morning when you wake up, put it
down in your ears like you're trying to
get wax out, and then in the middle of
the day like 3:00, you know, kind of
halfway between lunch and dinner, do it
again. Okay. And uh if that's correct,
what will happen is you're going to see
relief for 3 to 5 hours. Okay. Be
different.
And if it's in your hips, then it won't
affect it at all because it's in your
hips. Okay. Thank you so much. You're
very welcome.
Have an amazing day.
Oh, yes. Well, we're um just being here
with you is an amazing day. Thank you,
dear.
Okay, back to you.
Okay. My son, he's 4, he has severe
allergies. Um he's allergic to the top
eight and corn and um sesame seed. He
has extreme itching, eczema. I haven't
seen his skin clear since he was born.
Okay, so he has eczema. Does he have any
respiratory stuff or bowel things? Um he
had his he he was getting colonoscopies,
endoscopies. He was getting them since
he was
He'll be five next month. Five next
month. They're doing a colonoscopy on
him?
Tonsils, adenoids, reflux.
Yeah, we Yeah, we need a new doctor
here.
Okay.
Doing a colonoscopy on a five-year-old
kid, somebody needs to go to jail here.
I could say some things, but I won't.
Okay.
Um
I'm getting breathless here because of
this. Okay.
Um
basically, when a child has eczema and
bowel problems, it's because they have
what? A gluten intolerance. Right.
have asthma as a child? No. His father
did.
Well, that's not It's not going to come
from the father. Yeah, I did.
Okay. Even if the father had asthma,
it's not going to come from the father.
Uh does Are they Do you have any other
children? No. Uh do you have any
brothers and sisters?
Yes. Do they Any of them have asthma?
Yes. Bingo! There we go again.
Okay? So,
yourself,
your husband, the boy's father, the your
brothers and sisters, your mom if she's
still alive, all your mama's brothers
and sisters, your aunties and uncles,
all of them got to be gluten-free.
Okay, and what does this child weigh?
He's almost 40 and he is gluten-free
now, though. I don't believe it. Are you
gluten-free?
No. Well, then he's not gluten-free.
Okay.
Are the dogs and cats in the house
gluten-free?
He's allergic, so we don't have any.
Okay, what about anybody else living in
the house? Grandma? No.
Does he go to babysitters? He's at the
daycare. Daycare? Uh-huh. Are they all
gluten-free?
Is it Do you mean in the environment?
Yeah. Okay. Yeah, no. No. And so, he's
not gluten-free, then.
Okay.
Okay, cross-contamination, the food
preparation surfaces, the couch where
people watch TV, hugging people who just
had toast for breakfast, all the crumbs
all over their clothes.
Um
uh you know, even the daycare person,
you know, they they had a breakfast
sandwich at McDonald's and they're full
of gluten on their hands and they take
the child's hand and the child puts his
hands in his face and so
um a dog dog food for those of you do
have dogs, the dust from the dry dog
food or dry cat food gets on you. Um the
laundry where people wash their clothes,
you wash your clothes in the same
laundry as your child? No, I separate
that. Say again? I do it separately. I I
don't care if it's separate, is the same
washer and dryer?
Yeah, so you're getting
cross-contamination.
Okay.
I mean, you need to clean this
environment up. I mean, really be
obsessive about it, okay?
Okay.
And then, the child weighs 40 lb, you
say? Yes. Okay, well, approach him as 50
lb. So,
it'll be a one healthy brain and heart
pack. It'll last him 2 months.
So, a half a dose a day
for 2 months, right? And then, you need
to get another another one. As he gains
weight, the dose needs to go up.
And um
this should go away fairly quickly.
Okay? But, I would get another opinion
before you start doing colonoscopic
exams on a 4-year-old. I stopped taking
him to the doctor.
Oh, good. Yeah. Bless you. Yes. Okay.
Yeah. Okay.
Because, you know, how many of you have
heard of the trouble with priests who
are
who are predators on the choir boys and
stuff like that?
Well, there's a lot of sexual predators
who become pediatricians.
So, think about that.
Yes. Yes. God bless you, Dr. Wallach. Um
Thank you. concerning pain, um wherever
the pain may be, um um because I believe
because I'm a praying man, I haven't
take pain medicine in like 3 weeks and I
feel the same way I felt when I was
taking the pain medicine. So, what would
you prescribe?
Okay, now pain you're talking about
muscle, soft tissue, you talking about
joints?
any Every place. Yes, sir. Okay, have
you had a diagnosis from anybody?
Like fibromyalgia or arthritis, I mean
what did they tell you? I mean you know
you have pain, you didn't need to go to
doctor to say you have pain. So, what
did they tell you? They they're saying
that I had the condition and they and
because
What condition? Uh they said I had
arthritis. I don't believe Okay, so
let's say you have arthritis. You're a
big fellow, you need two healthy bone
and joint packs a month, right? Pull
those everything twice a day except for
the gluco gel, you're going to take 15 a
day and all that would be accomplished
by the
um two healthy bone and joint packs. You
can use the CM cream uh topically on
your knees, your hips, your elbows, your
shoulders, your neck, wherever you have
the pain. Soft tissue, muscles are fine.
And um
What kind of work do you do?
Um in hospitality, catering. I'm sorry,
say again. Hospitality, catering.
Hospitality, catering? catering, food
and beverage. Okay, you're you're not
the
cook, are you? No. Okay.
And you're rolling out flour and bread
and stuff, okay.
Yeah, you want to stay away from that
kind of stuff.
Um and none of the bad foods, no fried
foods, no processed meats, no all the
gluten. And also, you want to stay away
from carbonated drinks, even ones you
think of as being benign. Uh things like
um
uh ginger ale, club soda, sparkling
water, cuz the the um
carbonation actually uh
neutralizes stomach acid. It's going to
prevent you from absorbing minerals.
And so, you got to stay away from all
the carbonated drinks, too. Okay? Thank
you. You're bet. Yep. Yep. Question?
Hi. I got sick about 3 or 4 years ago.
Um
You want to step up to the microphone a
little bit.
Thank you.
Okay, I got sick about 3 or 4 years ago.
And I had pain and before I knew it I
was in the hospital. The kids took me to
the hospital and they examined me and it
was just like that. And the doctor said,
"Oh, your gallbladder is shot. We're
taking it."
So, they took your gallbladder out?
my gallbladder. So, I want to know
because they're saying I don't need it.
I don't believe that.
So, is there something
put it in there, you need it. That's my
point. Yeah. So, um is there something
is there a vitamin I can take? Is there
something I can do to offset all that?
Sure. Now, the question is, do you still
have any discomfort in your belly?
No. And it wasn't discomfort. I didn't
even know I was sick. I thought I was
having a heart attack. It was my first
event.
It just happened.
Oh, he said you had a heart attack?
No, I said I thought I was having a
heart attack. But they said it was my
gallbladder. But I had never gotten sick
before that.
Okay.
Um then, do you have any skin problems,
any eczema, dermatitis, psoriasis? I've
been in remission with the eczema for
about 20 some years.
20 some years, okay. Guess what? You
have a gluten intolerance.
Okay. So, you need to get off of all
gluten. No wheat bread or rye, oats, no
fried foods or processed meats or oils,
right? All that's got to go. Okay. Now,
the gallbladder, 99% of the time is
innocent. The gallbladder is just a bag.
And if you had any stones in there,
gallstones, they're made in the liver
and the liver drops them into the
gallbladder. And so, taking out the
gallbladder is kind of insane because uh
that's like amputating a weightlifter's
arms because he's got a big arm cuz he's
been weightlifting, right?
And so,
what I would do is go ahead and take a
two of the healthy brain and heart
patches a month, which is very good for
the liver.
Uh full dose of everything twice a day.
And then, specifically, we have what we
call the gallbladder in a bottle. It's a
It's a um
digestive program. And I want you to
take one or two, you'll decide which
one's better for you. One or two of
those ultimate enzymes, they're called
ultimate enzymes. Uh, like 1 to 2
minutes before each meal with a couple
ounces of water. It'll be maybe one
bottle a month. And we call it a
gallbladder in a bottle because it has
bile in it to help you absorb all the
good fats, including fat-soluble
vitamins A, D, E, and K, good
cholesterol, all the stuff you need to
absorb. You have to have bile from the
liver to do that. And your gallbladder
just stores the liquid bile. And when
you have a meal, it'll kind of squish
and all that bile goes in your
intestines and helps you absorb those
good fats. So, you do need that, and so
that's why we have the gallbladder in a
bottle called ultimate enzymes. Take one
or two of those 2 to 5 minutes before
each meal with a couple ounces of water,
okay? Okay. Thank you very much. You're
very welcome.
Okay, question.
Yes. Dr. Wallach, thank you for being
here. You're very welcome.
with
macular degeneration.
And I do have a spot in that right eye.
And
that's what I want to know.
Okay, she has macular degeneration. Did
you drive here yourself today?
No, my niece brought me.
Okay, can you drive? Yes, I can. Okay.
Um, macular degeneration is free radical
damage to the lining of the retina of
the eye.
And it's easily prevented and it's
easily reversed. It's not genetic in any
way, shape, or form. It's caused by free
radical damage to the eye. You got to
change everything you're doing. No fried
foods, no processed meats, no oils, no
gluten. All that's got to go.
Want you to remember that the eye is
part of the brain.
Okay? And the brain is part of the eye.
As the brain has the optic nerve, goes
through the skull, and then the eye is a
ball, you know, a ball on the end of
that optic nerve. So, it's all part of
the brain.
So, you need to get rid of all the bad
stuff, and particularly things that
produce free radicals. No fried foods,
no processed meats with nitrates,
nitrites, no oils, no gluten.
And um
You want to take two of the healthy
brain and heart packs a month, a full
dose with your breakfast and dinner.
And then I would also
um get your ORAC points, your
antioxidant points up to get rid of that
damage. It's kind of like having really
severe age and liver spots in the lining
of your eye.
And so um
what I want you to do
is there's three things you can take to
get your ORAC points up. And you kind of
mix them up. Um one this week, you know,
um another different one next week and
so on. So you can have a little variety
or you can do all the same thing. It
doesn't matter.
You need to get your ORAC points, your
antioxidant points above 100,000 per
day. ORAC is an acronym which stands for
oxygen radical
um
uh
capacity which is a measurement of how
many free radicals are neutralized by
the antioxidants in the product.
Anyway, um you can do that with either
what's called Cell Shield RTQ. Take five
of those twice a day.
Uh or you can take Triple Treat
Chocolate which is kind of fun. You take
six of those a day, two at breakfast,
lunch, and dinner if you like chocolate.
And uh or you can take what we call the
Beyond Tangy Tangerine BTT 2.0 tablets.
I'd go ahead and take three of those
twice a day. It'll be two bottles a
month. That's going to get your ORAC
points above 100,000 a day. Now the BTT
2.0 tablets
is a fairly economical way to get really
over 300,000 ORAC points a day. For me,
that's uh I would do the BTT 2.0 tablets
cuz I want 300,000 ORAC points. Although
100,000 will do the job, but my vision
is important to me. So I'm going to go
with the BTT. But any one of them will
work. You can mix and match them. Get
over 100,000 and these guys out there
will help you do that. And I made a bet
with a doctor once who called me a liar
who was in the group. I said, "I can I
can reverse macular degeneration even if
you're legally blind for 6, 8, 10
years."
He jumped up and said, "Wallach, you're
a liar."
So sir, who are you? He says, "Well, I'm
a medical doctor,
eye doctor, and absolutely it can't be
done. It's an age thing and you can't
stop it or or prevent it or cure it. He
says, "Well, sir, that's not correct.
You want to do a little wager?"
And um
He says, "Yeah, I'll do a wager with
you." He says, "Well, bring me 12 of
your patients that are legally blind 6 8
10 years of macular degeneration.
And if I could get half of them in 90
days, six out of the 12 to read 2020,
would you apologize?" He says, "If you
could get one
out of 12, I'll apologize." So, the next
day he brought me a box of 27 charts,
true story. He brought me 27 charts. I
had 300 witnesses in the room.
And um
He says, "Here, pick your 12." And I
said, "Well, who's going to pay for all
the supplements?" He says, "Well, let's
make that part of the wager. If you win,
I'll pay for it. If I win, you pay for
it." I said, "Well, that's fair." I
said, "If that's the case, let's go for
all 27." He says, "You're on."
So, I filled out a form as you're going
to have filled out there. And I I
personally gave it to each of the 27
patients. I talked to each one cuz I
would didn't quite trust him. You know,
I I didn't know if he was going to kind
of receive deep-six it so he could win
the bet. I don't know
cuz I didn't know him. And so, um I
talked to each of the patients and gave
them a written handwritten thing of how
to take the supplements.
90 days later, all 27, praise God, could
read 2020.
Only two required glasses to make it
happen. The other 25 didn't even need
glasses.
Now,
he apologized in public, but he even did
better than that. I just love that man.
He made me a CD and told the story of
the wager and tells how the thing went.
And we sell millions of those CDs every
year. It's called Seeing Is Believing.
Seeing Is Believing. And so, you need to
get that CD. Tell me you want the CD
Seeing Is Believing. And then, of
course, you want the two healthy uh
brain and heart pack per month. Okay, a
full dose of it at breakfast, full dose
of it at dinner time. I would also get
the Vision FX so you can take three of
those twice a day. It'd be two bottles a
month.
And uh Uh, let's see. I would also take
the
Take s y n a p t i v. Take three of
those twice a day. That's two bottles a
month, okay?
And then, uh,
call us every 2 weeks. Let us know how
it's going. Okay. Thank you.
bless. Dr. Wallach, we have an online,
um, question. Uh,
an online viewer has carcinoid cancer,
has already had his appendix removed
because of it. Is there a natural cure?
Okay.
Um, carcinoids tend to be only local.
They rarely go other places. They're
kind of a a local
malignancy where they just kind of grow
locally.
Uh, they rarely, if ever, go any place
else.
Uh, they are dangerous cuz if they erode
a blood vessel, you can bleed to death.
They can because they release chemicals,
you can get a stroke, and so forth. So,
they're not harmless, but uh, if if you
get cancer, that's one that's very
survivable. Carcinoid.
And so, um, what I would do is have them
change everything they're doing. Get
them on a gluten-free diet. No fried
foods, no processed meats, no oils.
And then, um, have them take a one
healthy brain and heart pack for 100 lb
of body weight. If they only weigh 120,
130 lb, get an extra bottle of selenium
so they can take a minimum of six of
those selenium a day, three at
breakfast, three at dinner, or two, two,
and two.
I would also have them take
the, um, BTT 2.0 tablets, three of those
twice a day so they can get their ORAC
points above 100,000 a day.
And, um,
uh, that will do wondrous things for
their immune system, which is their best
friend. We cannot use the cure word
here. There are certain limits on by law
that we can use the cure word. Um, I can
cure you of scurvy by giving you vitamin
C. I can cure you of rickets by giving
you vitamin D3. I can cure you of
beri-beri by giving you vitamin B1. I
can cure you of, uh, pellagra by giving
you vitamin B3. I can cure you of
pernicious anemia by giving you B12.
And then, it stops.
Cuz that's all the doctors know. They
They know about the other
um three essential nutrients.
And so by law I can't use the cure word
and you'll you've heard me several times
talk about supporting and promoting
maintenance repair. That's about as far
as I can go
um
uh if you have for instance
a bullet in you and surgically remove
the bullet, I can cure you of that
foreign body being you by taking the
bullet out. But there's certain limits
on what we can use the cure word for
because of how the medical system has
gotten things into the legal system.
Okay?
Okay. Did Did I answer the question? You
did. Okay, very good.
Yes.
Hi Dr. Wallach. God bless you for your
work you're doing.
Well, thank you. Very kind. I I love
God. Amen. I believe it. Um about 2
weeks ago I was taken to an emergency
cuz I had a racing heart
and they did all of the um preliminary
tests. They said my heart was fine. They
still want to do a um like a heart
monitor and um ultrasound on my heart.
you? Mhm. Yeah. Now that's that's
benign. That's fine. Okay.
And they have me on
I was already on a water pill and then
they put me on verapamil, I think it's
Verapamil, okay. Mhm. The lower dose.
Slow the heart down? Mhm. Okay. Now, let
me ask you a couple of questions. Is
that the first time you've had an
episode like that?
I had one um back in '09 cuz I had a
hemorrhage.
So my heart Sure. Speaking of When you
get anemic for any reason, whether it's
hemorrhage or nutritional deficiency,
your heart goes faster. And then in my
40s I think I used to
wake up and have the the rapid but it
would stop.
are you now? I'm 55.
55? How tall are you?
About 5 3 and 3/4. 5 3 and 3/4?
Now, have you shrunk any? Have you
shrunk a half inch or maybe an inch
since you were 20 years old?
No.
Would you bet your dinner on that? No.
Okay.
Now, you need to measure yourself.
just measured me and but she wasn't sure
cuz the way I had my hair that day, so
she wasn't sure whether I shrunk or not.
Yeah.
So, um
I'm going to say something here in a
minute, but I want to ask you a couple
more questions. Do you have any history
of any skin problems or asthma?
No. Any of your children or brothers and
sisters? No. Okay. Any bowel
I'm sorry. My sister. Oh, your sister
has what? She has asthma. Has asthma?
Mhm. Okay. Then you've got gluten
intolerance. She's got gluten
intolerance, right? Mhm.
And um
bowel problem, constipation, diarrhea,
irritable bowel syndrome, colitis,
diverticulitis, appendicitis, all that
stuff.
Anybody in your family have
appendicitis? No. Okay, but you do have
a gluten intolerance cuz your sister got
got um
asthma. I was working on that, but to
hear you talk, I'm not gluten-free. I
thought I was, but then you were talking
about the environment and all that.
You got gluten intolerance.
I believe it.
You can't deny it, dear. Okay.
No. Now,
the reason I asked you if you shrunk any
is because
there's a thing called atrial
fibrillation. Did the doctor talk to you
about A-fib or
atrial fibrillation?
He said something about sinus tachy- I
think.
Okay.
Yeah, sinus arrhythmias and that sort of
thing.
That's yeah, the part the thing that
controls the rate of your heart in the
heart.
But the main thing, can somebody want to
close that door back there, please?
Thank you.
Um
But the main thing that controls the
rate and rhythm of your heart are the
spinal nerves coming out from between
T1, 2, 3, and 4, the thoracic vertebrae,
the first four vertebrae in your back
after your neck, and then there's T1, 2,
3, and 4. When the discs shrink there,
those vertebrae get closer together and
they smash the roots of the spinal
nerves that control the rate and rhythm
of the heart.
Now, did these things happen when you
were laying down or sitting down or
getting up or reaching up or
when did it happen? You mean the heart
the heart rate?
Yeah, the rapid heart rate.
I was actually sleeping. They kept
asking me did it happen?
you were laying down? Mhm. Okay. Because
when I would sit up, I noticed it would
be a calm. Okay, you got it calmer when
you sat down when you sat up?
When I stand up.
Okay. Well, this is a positional thing.
This means that your vertebrae are
squeezing the roots of those nerves.
Either you got a bone spur on them, a
calcium deposit, which is osteoporosis,
or you've shrunk and those discs are
thinner than normal and the vertebrae
are squeezing the roots of the nerves.
Now, this is actually called atrial
fibrillation. Doctors will install
defibrillators, pacemakers. They may
have talked to you about that's a
possibility in the future. Yeah. Um they
will kill parts of your heart muscle
with electric shock to uh see if they
can find the part that's running wild,
as they call it. Um they can also then
do a retroversion where they electrocute
you to death hoping to reboot your heart
rhythm.
And uh then they can do a heart
transplant, none of which is going to
work because it's a back problem, not a
heart problem. Your insurance company
will pay out $500,000
to the doctor for a problem you do not
have.
They did say I have stenosis. Say again?
Stenosis.
I can't understand what you're saying.
Oh, they did say I have something called
stenosis, where the spine is narrowing.
Stenosis.
Oh, stenosis. Spinal stenosis. Yeah, it
could be spinal stenosis.
Yes, they said that I did have that.
Oh, there you go. There you had a back
problem. Okay. And was it up in your
back, high in your back or low?
I'm not sure. I'm thinking lower. And
then I have herniated discs also for
years and years.
Okay, there's a disc problems. Okay, so
yeah, you're this racing thing when
you're laying down is due to
degenerative disc disease. You sit up,
it goes away. And so what do you want to
do? Uh what do you weigh?
Uh about 150. 150? Would you take two
healthy bone and joint packs for a
month? Take a full dose of everything
twice a day except for the gluco gel,
which take 15 a day, five at breakfast,
five at lunch, five at dinner. All that
will be accomplished by the uh two
healthy bone and joint packs. You can go
ahead and put the CM cream on your neck.
You know, just like a teaspoon, put it
on your neck right down the middle and
the first four or five or six vertebrae
in your upper back between your shoulder
blades and on an inch on either side.
Use the CM cream.
And um
Uh it'd be very interesting. Take your
pulse. If you have one of these watches
or devices that'll take your pulse, you
can take your pulse um twice a day, just
record it in a logbook. But sit there
and for 10 minutes and calm down before
you take your pulse so you're kind of in
the same situation all the time. Okay.
Then give us a call. But the odds are
it's A-fib which is caused by a back
problem not a heart problem. Okay. Thank
you. You bet.
Okay, your turn.
Uh good good afternoon Dr. Wallach.
It is awesome you being here.
Well, thank you. Very kind. Uh um I uh I
have a family member that's um
that's been uh dealing with um COPD.
COPD, okay. Chronic obstructive
pulmonary disease, okay. Okay. And um
and and on top of it, you know, uh they
they've been dealing with um arthritis
like in their back and in their in their
knees. Sure.
Um
what can be done with that right there?
a big person? Do they weigh 200 lb or
100 lb or
Uh 200 lb
they're a little shorter than me. Okay,
so 200 lb. How old are they?
Uh 72. 72, okay. Well, COPD uh can be
caused by smoking if you eat lots of
caused by uh eating lots of fried foods
and getting scar tissue in the lungs.
Could be a short order cook inhaling,
you know, the vapors from frying foods.
Could be caused by working with
chemicals and dust. Could be caused just
by eating fried foods yourself and
causing the arteries in your lungs to
get scarred up and plugged up.
And so um
what I want them to do if they weigh 200
lb is to take two healthy brain and
heart packs a month.
Two healthy brain and heart packs for
month.
Then I want them to take the ultimate
daily classic, three of those twice a
day, okay? Two bottles a month of the
ultimate daily classic and this is to
dilate the arteries in the lungs, get
more blood flowing through there.
I also want them to take
uh two a day, one at breakfast, one at
dinner time of the ultimate uh cardio
sticks. Tear open the top, pour in a
bottle of water, let them drink it at
breakfast and dinner time.
And um of course none of the bad stuff.
Got to get rid of all the inflammatory
things that have done this. Uh no fried
foods, no processed meats, no also
gluten. I would also throw in one more
thing, which is an oxygen supplement
that's called OxyBody. They can take an
ounce an hour before each meal. If it's
a financial problem, you know, they
don't have to do it, but it'll speed
things up. Uh they can take uh an ounce
like a an hour before breakfast, an hour
before lunch, hour before dinner
or not at all, but it it'll help things
go faster cuz it's an oxygen supplement.
That's what it is. OxyBody, okay?
Comes in quart jars.
Okay.
Okay. God bless.
Okay, back to the center here.
Thank you for coming. Well, you're
welcome. My question is very simple. I
was diagnosed with a thyroid disorder
about 20 years ago. Okay, low thyroid
or hyperthyroid?
weight. I lost a lot I lost a lot of
weight.
lost a lot of weight. Okay, it could be
hyperthyroidism.
Yes. So, they put me on Synthroid and I
was told I would have to take this pill
for the rest of my life and that's what
I wanted
take your thyroid out or kill it with
They shrunk it with the iodine. They
shrunk it with radioactive iodine? Mhm.
Okay, but you still have it in there.
I think I do.
You tell me, you're the doctor. Okay.
But they shrunk it with the iodine.
That's what they did opposed to surgery.
Okay.
So, I'm taking this pill and I want to
know do I have
don't know if it's functional.
I guess I do. Cuz you're taking
hormones, right? Okay.
Okay, and So, I wanted to know do I have
to take this medication
Okay, well, you um
I would have them do a blood test
and see what's going on you know with
the hormones in your thyroid, the
hormones for your pituitary, TSH and
thyroxine stuff. They could give you a
clue whether your thyroid is dead or
alive so to speak.
But in the meantime what you want to do
is get rid of all the bad stuff out of
your life. The fried foods, the
processed meats, the also gluten. And
you also want to get rid of cruciferous
vegetables. Anytime you have anything
wrong with your thyroid, you want to get
rid of cruciferous vegetables. That
means no broccoli,
no cabbage, cauliflower,
Brussels sprouts or kale cuz they
interfere with thyroid.
And then
you want to take in addition to two
healthy brain and heart packs. One you
know one full dose at breakfast, one
full dose at dinner time. That'll last
you a month. Two full doses of the
healthy brain and heart pack per month.
You also want to throw in what we call
the Oceans Gold. Go ahead and take
three of those at breakfast, three at
dinner time. Two bottles a month.
And and that was how long ago they did
that with that About 20 years. 20 years
years Okay, 22 years ago. Okay.
And so the problem hasn't come back or
anything. They just check my levels.
Tell me if I need more or less.
Sure. Okay, well let's just do that.
Okay. Okay? Thank you. You bet. Okay.
Question.
afternoon.
I
Okay. Good.
I was diagnosed with alopecia and I was
told that because of my
thyroid condition, I take the synthroid
that it would be
irreversible. So I wanted to know if
there's some possibility
have alopecia universalis, kind of loss
of hair loss everywhere? Not everywhere.
Primarily here? Yeah. Okay.
Um
Well, interesting the Japanese have done
lots of research on male pattern
baldness. I am very interested in that
obviously.
Um in the research.
And
they say that male pattern baldness
primarily the head is due to a tin
deficiency. So, the nice thing about our
minerals is it has a lot of tin.
And I'd say 12-15 years ago, I mean, I
was like Yul Brynner. There was nothing
up there. So, I've grown a lot of hair
since I've been really upping my mineral
intake, probably because of the tin, but
I've also been gluten-free so I can
absorb stuff.
And so,
are these your real eyebrows? Okay,
that's good. Very good. And so,
I would go
with
two of the healthy brain and heart packs
for a month. Full dose of everything
twice a day. Two healthy brain and heart
packs for a month.
And then we have what we call hair,
skin, and nails. Go ahead and get two
bottles of that a month. Take three at
breakfast, three at dinner time.
And get rid of all the bad stuff.
All righty? So, that biotin, is that
something that's Biotin? Have you heard
of that? Biotin?
Many many people have suggested that for
hair,
nails. You're talking about eating
buffalo meat, bison? No.
Biotin.
No? Okay.
All right. All right. Thank you.
Okay. Thank you.
Okay.
Yes.
Thank you for being here. Very sweet.
Thank you.
Um I've been diagnosed with PMR,
polymyalgia rheumatica,
and I had a triple bypass 8 years ago. I
still have ongoing cardiac issues, so
I'm on Brilinta and
several other
medications.
Sure. So, my question is
um the PMR is kicking my butt. And I
want to know how to ease some of the
pain and the discomfort from that
disease.
Okay, PMR?
Polymyalgia rheumatica.
Rheumatica. Okay.
Yeah, another name for it is
fibromyalgia.
Um and so, they
me that it was different from
fibromyalgia
because they said it was worse than
I don't want to be worse, but I had two
doctors tell me that there was a
rheumatoid arthritis is more in the
joints and and in the soft tissue. But
it's it's a similar disease.
It's both.
Yeah, it's all and both of them are
related to lupus and that kind of thing.
Kind of a cousin to lupus, also. Oh. And
so what you want to do is get off of
gluten. No wheat, no rye, no barley, no
oats.
I'd go ahead and take two of the healthy
brain and heart packs a month. Take all
those every day at breakfast and all
those every day at dinner time.
Get yourself two bottles of the large
gluco gel. So you take 15 a day. Five at
breakfast, five at lunch, five at
dinner.
And
um for the discomfort,
uh
what you need to do is take what we call
the CM Plus capsules. Take three of
those twice a day. And it's going to be
a universal anti-inflammatory,
analgesic, pain relieving thing. And
don't cold turkey off of any of your
medication, particularly the pain stuff.
And so what you want to do is like How
often do you see the doctor?
Um every couple of months.
Every couple of months, okay.
Yeah.
So, you you start this now and again no
fried foods, processed meats, no sugars,
no gluten. And then when you go see him,
say, "You know, I'm feeling pretty good.
I've been changing my diet and taking
some supplements. And can you possibly
reduce the
the um
prescription of one or so of these
medications." Let the guy who wrote the
prescription do that. Okay?
Okay. Thank you.
You're very welcome.
Okay, over here. Yes.
Yes, hi. Good afternoon.
Um I have a child that was diagnosed
with ADHD at the age of five.
And he's been on medication since then.
Ritalin? Y- No, Adderall XR.
Adderall, okay. Yeah. So, do you have
any recommendation?
Sure.
Again, this is kind of the second time
we've touched on this. And so I want
everybody to listen up that has a child
or a grandchild or a cousin or somebody
with ADD, ADHD, regardless of age. Is it
a 4-year-old? He was diagnosed at five.
He's an adult now.
Oh, he's an adult now. Yes. But as an
adult, how old? 19. 19, okay. Young
adult.
So,
uh does he have any history of skin
problems, eczema, dermatitis, psoriasis?
Yeah, when he was younger, he had Yeah,
there's the bingo again. And so, he
can't absorb nutrients is a problem.
Because his intestines are damaged.
Remember seeing the rat intestines? He
doesn't have He doesn't have skin
problems now, though. It doesn't matter.
Okay.
Doesn't matter. He still has the
clinical symptoms of the deficiency,
which was caused by
Okay. So,
um do you have any other children? Yes.
Do any of them have any asthma or skin
problems? Skin problems.
Skin problems, okay. Yeah, they all have
a gluten intolerance. Do you have any
brothers and sisters? Yes. Do any of
them have skin problems or asthma?
No.
Anybody have any bowel problems, or
appendix out, anything like that?
No.
Okay, well if you have a gluten
intolerance, if you're all blood
brothers and sisters, then they got it,
too.
You need to talk about their kids, see
if any of their kids have any asthma or
bronchitis, or
a nephew with Has a nephew with asthma,
yeah.
a nephew with asthma.
it's it's through your whole family. So,
the whole family's got to be
gluten-free.
Then, 19 years old is he big fellow, or
small, or Thin and athletic.
Okay, athletic, and so maybe what, 180?
175?
180, 185. 180, okay. 180, 185. So,
he needs two Healthy Brain and Heart
Paks a month.
Follow those everything twice a day.
Um I would also
um
get him the Synaptive, so he can take
three of those twice a day, it'd be two
bottles a month, that's for the brain
function. Also, De-Stress, which has for
the metabolism of the brain, I'd have
him take three of those twice a day.
De-Stress, capital D like David
Stress.
And then, none of the bad stuff. No
fried foods, no processed meats, no
oils, no gluten,
no sugar in this case. And eventually,
he'll be able to eat a little bit of
sugar, like a sweet potato, or some
grapes, or something like that. But
right now, he's going to be totally
sugar-free. No juices, no fruit, dried
fruit, fresh fruit. Um vegetables will
give him everything he needs from fruit
without all the risk of sugar cuz sugar
contributes to these kind of things.
Uh makes them worse.
But this is a easily fixable thing, but
the the underlying problem is a gluten
problem. Can't absorb the nutrients and
this is why he's having problems. Okay?
Thank you. Okay.
Yes.
Good afternoon. I don't know where to
start. Pain goes all the way through my
body. I have narrowing here.
Degenerating spurs all the way down my
spine.
Okay, bone spurs up and down your spine?
Spurs and is that contributing to the my
legs?
Okay, yep.
The
uh the arthritis where there's times I
can't walk. Okay.
And when you lay down is it worse or
better?
Or the same?
of it's kind of the same. I can't sleep
on like an angle.
So you have to you find a place that's
the most comfortable?
they're trying to give me injections and
I don't want to do the injections.
Uh do you have any history of asthma,
bronchitis? No, just heart.
Okay, anything going on with um skin?
No. Okay, anything going on with bowels
like constipation, diarrhea, irritable
bowel syndrome? No. Appendicitis? None.
Kids have any of that? Brothers and
sisters have any of that? No. I'm still
going to put you on a gluten-free diet
anyway. Okay. Okay, no gluten, no wheat,
barley, rye, oats, no fried foods and
processed meats and oils are gluten.
And then you want to take two of the
healthy bone and joint packs a month.
Two healthy bone and joint packs a
month. Mhm. A full dose of everything
twice a day except for the gluco gel, 15
a day, five at breakfast, five at lunch,
five at dinner.
And uh you can use the CM cream that
come with those two healthy bone and
joint packs. Apply that to your knees.
Okay, and if you get you know, the pain
is 50% better but not totally gone, we
have what we call trauma oil. It's a
blend of aromatherapy. All you got to
apply four or five drops of that in a
teaspoon of the Okay.
um CM cream and apply that to your knees
or hips or your backs. Have somebody put
on your back for you. Those spurs will
go away without surgery. They'll just go
right back into the bone.
Uh bone spurs always occur within your
heel, your vertebrae, your neck, uh your
elbows.
Um bone spurs always occur where a
tendon or ligament hooks into the bone.
And as you move your muscles and bend
over and twirl around,
those tendons and ligaments pull on the
bone,
and the spur kind of comes up or a
calcium deposit comes up. You take the
right nutrients, they'll support and
promote maintenance repair, they go
right back into the bone.
Okay. Okay, do you not get surgery for
that stuff?
No, they were trying to do all that. I
won't Yeah, no, no. Don't get the
surgery. Don't let them put rods or
wires or plates or any Stay away from
all that. How about the injections that
Well, have they worked for you?
No. Okay, have you ever heard that
insanity is doing the same thing over
and over and expecting a different
result?
Albert Einstein said that, and I'll take
his word for it, right? Okay. Yeah, and
so just remember, your doctor has to
make a living.
Well, we go we go at it all the time.
Good. Well, don't If you go at it all
the time, you know, I'd I'd stay away
from that doctor. Yeah.
You can fire him online. The phone book
is full of hungry doctors.
Yeah. So, I I I end up leaving without
taking the shots, so the whole staff is
like like looking at me like, "Really?"
And I'm like, "Yes, really." Yeah. No.
Yeah, well, see, when they get somebody
on a trail, again, this is what Dr. King
was going after. Mhm. Um just like a
mammogram. Okay, well, it's all highly
suspicious here. We're going to err on
the side of conservatism here. We're
going to do a biopsy. Well, the biopsy
is unequivocal. We can't quite tell for
sure. We're still going to do get you on
chemotherapy and radiation and do a
mastectomy because that's a prudent
thing to do.
Okay? And so, they're going to run you
through hundreds of thousands of dollars
worth of treatment
Yeah.
didn't need it because they need the
income to get their kids through
college. Well, I ask the questions that
people don't want to ask. So, it's good.
Yeah. So, yeah. Thank you. You're very
welcome.
God bless you, doctor. Well, Um I know
God loves me. I I love that part.
I'm standing in stead for my sister.
She's been on dialysis for 4 years.
And does she have diabetes also? No.
Okay, so she got kidney failure. Yes.
Okay.
Um when you have kidney failure, there's
nothing wrong with your kidney.
I'm going to say that again cuz it
strikes people as very interesting.
When you have kidney failure, there's
nothing wrong with your kidneys.
I'll give you an example.
Let's say you're taking a shower
and the water's coming up around your
ankles, around your knees, and flows
over into the into the floor in the
bathroom. So you have your cell phone,
you call
uh a um
home appliance place and say, "Look, I
need you to come out here and replace my
bathtub."
Is that the right thing to do? No. What
you want to do is call the plumber and
say, "Hey, I need the willow tree roots
rooter-rooted out of the drain because
the tub won't drain."
So when you have a kidney failure,
there's nothing wrong with your kidney.
Putting on dialysis may be life-saving
for a couple of weeks, but after that
you shouldn't need it.
And so they'll put you on there for a
couple of years until they really need
some serious money, then they'll find a
kidney for you to get a kidney
transplant.
But I've had people that haven't
urinated in 10 years. They're on
dialysis six times a a week.
And after a couple of months, they're
urinating again.
After another couple of months, they're
off of dialysis. It's easy to get people
off of dialysis.
What you have to do, remember the
kidney's okay.
The reason why the kidney's not working
is not because there's anything wrong
with the kidney, it's because the blood
vessels that carry the dirty blood into
the filtering unit are plugged.
So our goal here is to get blood flowing
into the filtering units.
So what you do, you're sort of a
medium-size woman, right?
What do you weigh?
She She is Oh, she is. What does she
weigh? Yeah.
What weighs What does she weigh, you
think?
Um 150, 180? 150.
150, okay. So I'd give her two Healthy
Brain and Heart Paks per month.
Okay, for just the general stuff,
everything her kidneys and liver and
heart and brain need all that stuff.
But also
I'd get her the Ultimate Daily Classic
tablets.
Have her take three of those three times
a day. Three at breakfast, three at
lunch, three at dinner.
And um
then I'd have her take
um two a day of the ultimate uh cardio
sticks, one at breakfast, one at dinner
time. I'd also have her take two a day
of the ultimate niacin plus. They are
non-flush, they are time release. Have
her take one at breakfast, one at dinner
time. That's one bottle a month. The
whole idea here is to dilate those
arteries going into the kidney, the ones
that are already in the kidney, the
arteries um the little afferent arteries
are like 10,000 times the the smaller
than the diameter of your hair. They
carry the red blood cells one at a time
into the filtering units. Sometimes
those arteries are so small, the red
blood cell has to fold over like a taco
to get through there, right?
And um
this program will support and promote
healthy blood flow through those blocked
arteries into the kidney, and the kidney
will wake up out of its hibernation and
start working again.
And sometimes I'm sure they're taking a
blood test every month and just putting
it in the book like they're supposed to.
Well, suddenly now they're going to see
that there's improvement on the
filtration rate,
and they're going to say, "We need to
redo your test here. That doesn't seem
right." And it'll it'll be right.
And so it might take a couple of weeks,
it might take a couple of months, but
it'll happen, okay? But she's it'll
happen the quickest when she stays away
from the fried foods and processed
meats, the oils and gluten, cuz that's
what plugs the arteries.
Okay? Thank you. You're welcome.
Okay, you can
Hello? Hi. I
and kidney failure.
Okay, so you have kidney failure? Yes.
And you have Do you have diabetes? No.
Okay, I I missed the first one then.
Kidney disease.
Okay, kidney disease, okay. Kidney
failure. And you're a big fella, what do
you weigh? 220. 220.
Okay, so you're going to How long you've
been on dialysis? 3 years. 3 years,
okay.
Uh I would do the same thing as this
lady's friend. You need two healthy
brain and heart packs a month.
Um
I'd go ahead and um
get the um, ultimate daily
classic. Go ahead and take nine of those
a day. That'll be two bottles a month.
Three at breakfast you're big fella. I'd
have you take three at breakfast, three
at lunch, three at dinner. I'd also have
you take um, two of the ultimate cardio
sticks
um, a day.
Maybe three. Maybe three. Take one at
breakfast, one at lunch, one at dinner.
So it'll be three. It'll be three boxes
a month. They come in boxes of 30. It's
a financial thing. Don't go any lower
than two
um, a day. I would also do the um,
ultimate niacin plus. I'd go ahead and
get two bottles of those ultimate niacin
plus. So you can take two at breakfast
and two at dinner time. And that's again
going to dilate these arteries, get the
blood flowing through. Uh, that's the
whole idea of kidney failure. Now, you
got to stop the ongoing damage. Now, the
interesting thing about when you have
plugged arteries going into the kidneys
and you require kidney dialysis to keep
all the blood values correct.
That's not the only place in your body
you got blocked arteries. You're going
to get them in your brain and get
vascular dementia. You're going to get
them in your eyes and get glaucoma.
You're going to get them in your heart
and get coronary artery disease
because
you the the arteries in your body don't
get obstructed in just one little place.
Because all the fried foods and
processed meats and oils and gluten
affect every artery in the body. So,
you're getting a warning that there's
something bad happening in other places,
right? And especially being a male,
being a man, um, we tend to have worse
uh, results than women when it comes to
these things.
And so, that's uh, you need to
appreciate that. You need to be really
serious about keeping away from the
fried foods and processed meats and oils
and gluten. That includes dog food in
the house has to be dry dog food. It's
got to be gluten-free. It's got to be
rice and lamb. The first four
ingredients cannot be wheat, barley,
rye, and oats.
Cat food, bird food, fish food, spouse,
mother-in-law, kids. Everybody in the
household. If you have any brothers and
sisters, if your mom's still alive,
aunties still have them on your mom's
side. Everybody's got to be warned. If
you have sisters, blood sisters, their
children will have the same problem.
Okay? So, it's important. Thank you.
Okay, you're very welcome, sir.
Good afternoon. Hi.
I'm a 48-year-old mother of six, and I'm
having trouble
just keeping my I guess my body
temperature to stay warm.
I'm usually cold all the time. When
everybody else is hot, I'm usually cold.
Um I had blood work done. Only thing my
doctor said I need was vitamin D.
Your doctor said I just need vitamin D.
To take vitamin D.
I'm missing that body
And your doctor said you need
I'm usually always cold all the time.
Yeah, I understand. The doctor just told
me I need to take vitamin D. They did
blood work on me.
Vitamin D. Yeah, just to take vitamin D.
I got you. Okay.
Um how much do you weigh? About 150.
Okay. And you have children? I have six.
You have six, okay.
Yes. Um any of them have any health
problems, asthma, bronchitis, skin
Yeah, we all have asthma. Oh.
Okay, what's the problem, ladies and
gentlemen? Gluten. You got it. You got a
gluten intolerance. Okay. Your brothers
and sisters, your mom if she's still
alive, all your babies need to be
gluten-free. Man living in the house,
spouse or
Okay. I baby sit. You baby sit? Baby
sit, okay. Uh but a man, spouse,
mother-in-law,
um kids, what do what do you work
outside the home?
Yes. And what kind of work do you do? Um
I work as a ambassador and I do
security.
Oh, your mom's an ambassador? I said me.
You said what kind of work do I do?
Okay.
Okay. Do you know karate and all that
stuff? No, sir, I do not. Okay.
But if I have to take somebody down, I
could. Yeah.
Okay. That's an equalizer, isn't it?
Okay.
Okay, so anyway,
yeah, at 150 lb, um I'd go ahead and
have you take again two Healthy Brain
and Heart Paks a month.
Okay?
And I want you to take the um
Ultimate Daily's uh classic Ultimate
Daily classic. Take three of those twice
a day. And I'll also have you take uh
just try something as simple as the
ultimate niacin plus. Take one of those
at breakfast and that would be one
bottle a month. Keep the cost down for
you.
And the idea is to dilate the blood
vessels in your hands and your feet.
Um have you shrunk any in height since
you were a child? I may have. Okay.
Possible, okay. So yeah, you want to
measure yourself now and go back and
think how tall when I was I when I was
18 and how tall am I now? Have I shrunk
an inch or half inch or something?
Because that can impact cuz you can
actually smash some of these nerves
which will um in your back which will
clamp down on the blood vessels going
into your feet and hands and have cold
hands and feet because of a back
problem. That's also a possibility.
And um and so but it's going to be
imperative to get the whole household
gluten-free. Okay? And be aware of that
when you're around people and you're
doing your security job and stuff. Be
real careful about uh shaking hands with
people you just saw. Oops.
Oh, she needs to be a pitcher.
That's pretty good.
Okay. Okay? Okay. Thank you for your
service.
Okay.
Okay, I think we've got about uh 5 more
minutes. Is that right, Pastor? Would
that make it an hour?
Is that correct? How much more time we
have?
I'm sorry?
How much more time do we have to make it
an hour?
5 minutes, okay. So we're going to take
one here, one here, one there. I
apologize. We'll have to end it there,
but
you can still have a relationship with
Youngevity. We're going to be around for
generations and generations and
generations. And these folks out at the
table will be able to help you. I don't
know how long they're going to stay out
there and do that. But you can write
things down
and you can call us. They'll give you
toll-free numbers and internet and so
forth. And so you'll find that that um
we're going to help you. It might take a
couple extra days, but we will help you.
Okay? Yes. Good afternoon. Um my husband
just recently had heart surgery to
replace a heart valve about 3 weeks ago.
And um he also got a pacemaker.
So, when he came home, he's on about
seven or eight different medicines. So,
I was wondering is there anything that
we could do to maybe reduce the amount
of medicine he'll be taking ongoing?
let me ask you a couple of questions. Um
before he had the valve replacement and
the pacemaker installed, did he have any
diagnosed heart disease other than the
valve thing? Did he have congestive
heart failure? Um that's why we went to
the hospital because he was having
trouble breathing.
Okay, fluid in his lungs?
And so, they did tests and they came
back and said it was congestive heart
failure.
Yeah. Okay, well, remember congestive
heart failure is caused by deficiency of
a single vitamin.
And I would have opted for a couple of
weeks on the you know, maybe diuretics
to get the fluid out of his lung and get
him on the supplement program. Well, now
they put a valve in, which you now we
got to deal with that.
And so, now what does he weigh? Is he a
big fellow or medium-sized?
Um when he went in, he was about um 230.
Now, he's down to about 218. Okay, so 12
lb of that was uh fluid.
All right. And so, what I would do is
give him two of the healthy um brain and
heart packs a month.
Full dose of everything twice a day.
Healthy brain and heart packs a month,
two per month. I'd also give him the
de-stress capsules. I'd have him take um
nine of those a day for a couple of
months and then drop it down to
three twice a day, but uh three three
times a day. That'll be three bottles a
month cuz that has that vitamin that's
necessary for the congestive heart
failure. And so, I want him to take
those and also I want him to have the
ultimate cardio sticks.
Uh one twice a day, that's two boxes a
month. I want him to take the ultimate
um
daily classic. He could take three of
those twice a day, that's two bottles a
month.
And let's see here.
I want to make sure uh that he's off all
the bad stuff. In his case, fried foods
processed meats, oils, and gluten, but
he also has to stay away from sugar. Uh
sugar um is one of the evil things when
people have congestive heart failure and
you're deficient in that vitamin. It can
also result in dementia and other
problems. So, we want to make sure that
he's taking those uh
uh three of the D-Stress capsules three
times a day.
And um
no fried foods or processed meats or
oils, no gluten, no sugar.
No sugar from fruit, see there? No
fruit. Okay.
No fruit juices. He can have all the
vegetables he wants. And you can melt
butter and put them on the steamed
vegetables. You know, don't cook them in
oil or anything like that cuz that's
going to contribute to the problem,
okay? Okay, thank you.
goal here is to tone his heart up. So,
the heart kind of tones up to its
optimal size. Usually, when you have
congestive heart failure, it's bigger
than normal and those valve leaves don't
meet. Right. And so, when you tone up
the heart and it gets smaller and it's
the right size, suddenly all those valve
leaflets meet. Oh, okay.
Okay, so that's why I say I I would have
wanted to be given a month
before surgery would have been a an
option.
Okay.
anyway, we're here we're at we're at
now. And so, we'll do great with him,
okay? Okay, thank you.
bless. Okay, last one.
Yes, ma'am? Hi, good afternoon, doctor.
Um as a medical professional myself, I
just wanted to know um and I'm further
you a nurse or doctor? No, I'm actually
a medical assistant. I'm furthering my
education with hopes to become a doctor.
Okay, let's give her a hand.
And after hearing what you said and
stuff, I was wondering if you had like
any mentorship programs, any educational
programs, and where do I go from here?
Okay, what you want to do is talk to
those folks out the table and let them
know you're interested in going further
cuz we're looking for everybody to join
us in this mission cuz it's a God
mission.
And um we do have actually, I'd say a
couple of dozen pharmacists who work
with us. We have a um
couple of dozen uh PAs, physician's
assistants. We have maybe 100
chiropractors, 100 naturopathic
physicians.
We have quite a few Chinese traditional
medical and um
uh
doctors.
Um lots of nurses, every kind of nurse
you can think of, probably hundreds of
nurses.
So, we're very, very proud of the
medical professionals who do associate
with us.
And uh as a medical technician, you're
going to see things in the clinic and
the hospital and stuff. And you know, in
all professions, in all professions,
there's always room for improvement,
right? Only God is perfect.
And so, um it pays for us to be kind of
a watchdog on behalf of the public and
you know, keep the doctors' feet to the
fire, so to speak, so they're doing all
the right stuff. And a doctor, "Are you
sure you want to give that dose to a
3-year-old kid? That's a 300-lb man's
dose." "Oh, thank you. Thank you. Yeah,
I got the wrong decimal point." And so,
we want to be watchful for uh people
because we we can save lives by doing
that. But also, our goal is to educate
as many medical professionals as
possible. But I will tell you
that I have
probably about uh
250,000 what I call PAs that I pay every
month. 250,000. These are not
physician's assistants. They're my
personal assistants, so I call them my
PAs.
And
I have people who are ninth-grade
dropouts
that know what to do for congestive
heart failure and get rid of it, get
them off the heart transplant list
they've been on for 3 years and 2 weeks.
Okay? These are high school dropouts,
ninth-grade dropouts. I have people with
high school educations who are in charge
of 500,000 people
who take care of 500,000 people each
month, all with the internet and so
forth. And they feed me information, but
they're using these pre-programmed
packages that we have for these 900
different diseases.
And so, you don't have to go to school
for 8 years to become a brain surgeon or
something like that to do these things.
Although, we we appreciate brain
surgeons who do come with us.
Um and so, I was saying those things for
the rest of you out here. If you're
interested in becoming a student of this
information,
this will give you an enormous amount of
what should I say, points with your
community because you're going to be
doing God's stuff.
Okay? And the beautiful thing about this
is these individuals do not pay you
anything.
I pay you.
Very you see, I
we're
a very large publicly traded company.
I'll just tell you that much. You can
look us up and you can look up our
income and everything. We're a very
large publicly traded company.
I've been doing this for 38 years and I
personally have have never taken a
single penny from the corporation.
I don't have to take a penny from I make
my living selling books.
Okay? Thank you.
And
I did that for several reasons cuz I
didn't want people to think I I'm I
believe that I'm doing God's work cuz
how does a 9-year-old kid figure this
out? So, I figured God gave it to me
when I was nine.
Okay? Been doing this since I was 9
years old.
And so, I purposely chose not to take
any income from the sale of these
products and from the services
purposely for two reasons. Number one,
because I didn't want somebody to say,
"Well, I may need this stuff, but I'm
not going to take it cuz I don't want
Wallach to make any money."
So, I didn't want that to be in play. I
also didn't want to be in play that
medical doctor would say, "Well, just
how much money you're making with that
quackery stuff, Wallach?"
Okay? How much money are you making? I
said, "Well, I don't take any money. I
don't take a fee from these people. I
don't make a penny from the sale of any
of these products. I make not one single
penny from the sale of any of the
products. I take no office call fees,
nothing."
Uh I I give free service. Been giving
free service for 38 years.
Doctor, how many free patient services
you do?
And so, but and you don't get paid
unless you're a licensed doctor and you
want to do that out of your office,
you'll get paid an office visit, all
right? But
I urge you not to do that unless you're
a licensed health professional.
Uh and you'll make more money than they
do
doing this because America needs us
badly. The world needs us badly.
And um
you become a student of this
information, people will know that
you're a member of a healing church,
right? And they will come to you and
say, "You I hear you can help people
with diabetes. You can help people with
high blood pressure. You can help people
who are on the heart transplant list,
who are on the kidney dialysis uh
laboratories every three times a week."
And you'll be able to help them and the
word gets out and out and out. And
the
thing that that um
has made America weak
is we had more jobs than we had
businesses.
Now you think, "Well, wait a minute.
Jobs were good." Well, jobs are good,
but what I said was we had more jobs
than businesses.
Okay, that's a bad thing. The nice thing
about this is you can keep your job.
I don't want you to quit your job. You
keep your job, get, you know, do your
best thing you can do for that job, keep
getting raises and do and and be a good
part of the company.
But also,
how many tax breaks can you get when
you're an employee?
None.
When you own your own little Youngevity
business,
you get the same tax breaks as Bill
Gates, Warren Buffett, Donald Trump, and
all the billionaires.
Okay? Let's say you're having trouble
with your
with your um
insurance with the company you're
working and they take you from a
full-time employee to part-time so they
don't have to pay insurance anymore.
Or maybe your insurance company says,
"Well, you know, your your deductible
used to be $300 and now it'll be 3,000."
Suddenly now that insurance is not so
attractive. So what you can do, shop
around,
and then you you write yourself a little
business plan.
And in this business plan you say, "My
little Youngevity business is going to
pay for my
monthly health insurance premiums, my
monthly life insurance premiums, and my
fitness center memberships."
Well, I'm not making that much money
yet. It might take a year to or two to
make that much money. No problem.
Out of your pocket, you write a check
into your business checking account,
and you'll loan it with a piece of paper
that says you're making a loan each
month to pay that through your company
system,
and then when your company's making that
much it'll pay you the money back. But
in the meantime, you get tax deductions
and you're going to get back almost all
of or all of your withholdings,
which is amounts to several thousand
dollars a year. You get those that back,
which is money the government would do
silly things with.
Okay? You have more money to tithe to
the church.
Okay? So, these are the things you can
do when you own your own business.
Uh it's amazing. All the tax laws, all
the benefits, the real real hard
benefits that we get as Americans are
for people who own their own business.
Okay. You got it? Yes. Thank you.
Okay, last one. Okay.
Good afternoon. Um approximately 10
years ago my husband was diagnosed with
sarcoid- sarcoidosis. Okay.
And um
the most recently he had a sinus surgery
and unbeknownst to the doctor, the
sarcoid was in his nose.
Now,
now I missed the first part of that cuz
I couldn't hear it from down there.
Oh. My husband was diagnosed with
sarcoidosis.
Okay. So, most recently he had a sinus
surgery and the doctor did not know at
the time that the sarcoidosis was in his
nose.
So, now he is having a lot of trouble.
He He gets about 3 hours of sleep per
night. And how much does he weigh? He
weighs 240 lb.
240? Okay. Does he have any other issues
other than the sarcoidosis, any high
blood pressure, diabetes?
Uh high blood pressure. High blood
pressure. Okay.
Uh any kidney issues, any kidney
failure? No. Okay. Any constipation,
diarrhea? No.
Skin problems, eczema, dermatitis,
psoriasis?
Uh eczema. Eczema. Okay. Well, what's
the problem? Gluten.
Gluten. So, you got gluten problem. Now,
sarcoidosis is a close cousin to lupus
and fibromyalgia. Okay?
It's caused by a gluten intolerance, not
being able to absorb the minerals
properly, right? Even if you're
supplementing with them. So, he's got to
be and you got to be the dog, the cat,
the bird, the fish, kids in the house,
his brothers and sisters, his mama, all
his aunties and uncles on his mama's
side have got to be drop-dead
gluten-free. Okay? No wheat, no bread,
no rye, no oats, no fried foods, no
processed meats, no oils. Now, I would
give him two healthy brain and heart
packs a month, a full dose of everything
twice a day.
I would also give him the um
um
Immortaleum. It's the first time I've
said it tonight, Immortaleum. Uh which
is it stimulates stem cells. Stem cells
regrow stuff like joints and cartilage
and ligaments and tendons, uh lung
tissue. It'll support the regrowth of um
uh
stem cells for healthy intestines and so
forth, skin.
And so, I'd have him take uh three of
those Immortaleum twice a day. It's two
bottles a month.
And again, no fried foods, processed
meats, oils, or gluten.
And um it's amazing how quickly they
show benefit. Usually, 4 to 6 weeks,
you're going to see something
recognizable. He'll notice things within
4 to 6 weeks where they're recognizable.
If he has pain, uh inflammation inside
or pain in any joints or muscles or
anything, he can use the CM Plus
capsules
orally. Take three of those twice a day.
It'll be two bottles a month. He can use
the CM cream topically where he has pain
in a joint or muscle or tendon.
And he'll get relief for about 3 to 5
hours. He might have to do it twice a
day.
Okay? Thank you.
You're welcome. Okay. Now, just kind of
a final thing here.
Again,
when you order these products, you're
going to pay wholesale. We don't charge
retail for any of these things when you
join us. You're going to pay wholesale.
You're going to pay the same thing I pay
when I buy my products. The company
doesn't even give me products. They said
up I have to buy my own products.
So, everything everybody who buys from
our company are going to buy only
wholesale.
You can get free shipping if you get on
what's called auto ship cuz the computer
generates everything and how how goes.
It saves us a lot of time, money, and
energy, so we pass that savings on to
you. We'll pay the shipping.
If you get on auto-ship, you can always
change it. If you want to reduce this,
add this, you can always do that without
any penalty or fees.
Um and so you want to consider that.
Also,
every time you
get three people started, let's say you
get three people started just on the
basic program, the healthy start pack,
just the 90. You get three people in a
month do that, I'll give you a healthy
start pack for free.
If you just get three new people
started, you'll get one for free. If you
do that every month for 100 years, you
get one every month free for 100 years.
Okay, it's not just a one-time deal.
And this is for everybody. You You don't
have to be a distributor. You don't have
to even pay the $25 one time. It's free.
Even as a um preferred customer, we call
it.
And so, you can go as fast or slow. You
can be a customer for 100 years. We love
you. We don't force anybody to become
distributors. Uh it's there if you want
it.
You don't have to be involved in it if
you don't want to be. Okay?
I want to thank you for being such a
kind family, for welcoming me in. We
love you. God bless you. Look forward to
working with you. Thank you very much.
Thank you.